this morning we know the names of nearly
all of the 26 people killed in the
shooting a pregnant woman and her unborn
child are among the dead the oldest
person killed was 77 years old and
Michelle Miller is here in Sutherland
Springs now with a look at some of the
victims Michelle Des Moines good morning
Jeff nearly half of the people killed
were just from two families an
unfathomable loss but each and every
person who died inside that church is
part of a larger community bonded by
faith if you start thinking about who
these people in your life would be that
would be taken all at one time like that
it's not comprehensible the Holcomb
family lost nine members in all
grandfather Brian Holcomb and his wife
Carla Brian's son Mark and his daughter
Noah crystal Holcomb her unborn child
and three of the couple's children
Emily Meg and Greg also died earl season
good is a close friend they're not lost
and they're not done their last breath
here their nest breast was in heaven so
there was the Lord Himself we laughed
together we cried together and we
worship together in addition to the loss
of their congregation Shari Pomeroy and
her husband pastor Frank Pomeroy will
bury their daughter
fourteen-year-old Annabelle in a video
from July Annabelle talked about the
concept of forgiveness if you believe in
them you can get high school sweethearts
Robert and Shane e Corrigan also died
they have two sons on active duty Robert
was a retired Air Force veteran and took
an active role at the First Baptist
Church sharing this prayer two weekends
ago we just pray that you continue to
bless this church in this community
Bob Sommers is Robert Corrigan's uncle
we feel the support
of everybody or think bobby was an
amazing man and Jeff to think that those
two sons who were trained to put their
lives on the line each and every day
they had to be notified that their
parents that they would have to come
home and bury their parents because of
an unknown threat on the home front it's
just it's just one of those ironic
twists of faith it's terrible to hear
about us or someone in the stories here
Michele thank you very much
Gill the scope and impact of this
tragedy in such a small town is complete
and it is heartbreaking it's always
heartbreaking Jeff when you start
hearing the personal stories of the
victims that were lost so senselessly I
still can't wrap my brain around this
thank you so much